Bonjour c'est Cyprien,
et je voulais vous parler d'une musique.
Le titre c'est '' Le même que moi''.
C'est un duo entre un mec de 24 ans et un gamin de 10 ans.
Si vous connaissez pas, c'était le troisième single le plus acheté la semaine dernière
et le deuxième clip le plus diffusé à la télévision.
Et si vous connaissez toujours pas, bien...
VOUS CHERCHEZ SUR GOOGLE, COMME TOUT LE MONDE, HEIN
J'aimerais vous faire une petite critique.
Bon bien déjà, dès la première seconde, il y a un problème.
Ce mec dort habillé.
Ce type est déjà chelou.
[ musique ]
Juste après dans le clip, le mec dit :
♪ Petite énergumène, voudrait me ressembler ♪
Non, non non je pense pas non.
Qui aimerait ressembler à un type qui porte un chapeau pour se donner un genre et une chemise en jean?
Ensuite il y a le refrain.
Et là, non. Non, non, ce n'est pas possible.
♪ Il est le même que moi ♪   ♪Non, non il ne faut pas l'écouter, je ne veux pas lui ressembler yeah  ♪
Ce gamin ne parle pas français.
Je veux bien qu'il soit jeune, mais quand même, à dix ans tu sais t'exprimer!
Le verbe "Ressembleiller" n'existe pas.
Suite du refrain.
♪ Il est le même que moi ♪  ♪ Tu rêves, je crois c'est sûrement pas, sûrement pas,  Non Non yeah yeah yeah ♪
Ceci n'est pas une phrase.
Où est le COD? Où est la fin de la phrase? Parce que non non yeah yeah yeah, ce n'est pas une fin de phrase.
Emmenez ce gamin à l'école, au moins une fois dans sa vie, s'il vous plait.
Et bien voilà, là je préfère.
Attends, attendez! STOP STOP STOP.
Ah d'accord, je comprends mieux.
Le mec a 24 ans et il va au CE2.
Tout s'explique, tout est beaucoup plus clair maintenant, hein.
Dormir habillé tout ça...
Enfin non, dans le clip ils disent que le grand va à l'école...
♪ c'est pour voir si la nouvelle maîtresse va lui plaire ♪
Non, non. Là, je dis non.
Si vous avez suivi un petit peu, au début du clip, ils dorment dans la même chambre.
Donc soit le grand, il péchaut pas, dans ce cas-là il y a pas de problème pour dormir dans la chambre du petit frère.
Sois il péchaut, avec le petit qui dort à côté.
Je trouve ça un petit peu glauque quand même.
[ couinements de lit ]
Maîtresse?
Un peu plus loin dans le clip, vous allez me dire si il n'y a rien qui vous choque.
♪ Et j'en suis fier, car il a tout pour plaire  ♪  ♪Il est le même que moi ♪
♪ Tu rêves je crois c'est sûrement pas, sûrement pas, non non non yeah yeah ♪
Je n'ai jamais vu quelqu’un, galérer autant à mettre une veste.
[ musique rock ]
J'aimerais terminer sur le nom des chanteurs.
Bon bien, déjà le gamin s'appelle Léo, comme 50% des enfants qui sont nés en 2001.
Je rappelle que les autres 50% s'appellent Enzo, voilà, il y avait que deux prénoms en 2001. Restriction budgétaire.
Et le grand s'appelle: Gary Fico.
Je suis désolé, mais Gary, c'est le nom de l'escargot dans Bob L'Éponge.
Et Fico...Bien c'est "chicot", prononcé par un mec qui zozote.
Dire que je pensais avoir un prénom pourri, j'aurais pu m’appeler Gary Fico, quoi.
Si vous ne pouvez pas vous blairer cette musique, partagez ma vidéo sur Facebook et rejoigniez ma page.
Et puis vous pouvez aussi aller sur Cyprien.fr pour voir toutes mes autres vidéos.
Et soyez contents. Ça aurait pu s’appeler GaryFico.fr